supergirl is a thrilling TV series that
always keeps us on our toes fans have
been waiting for season 4 to come to a
close and they've come up with some
pretty interesting theories of their own
keep watching to find out which main
character is predicted to become the
almighty superwoman what if we could
make people super it's not possible
Mao's marriage is a lie we love Kara
Danvers so we're super crushed women l
had to return to the 31st century and
leave her behind her heartbreak was
impalpable so caramel shippers were
stoked when Mon L finally returned to
Cara's timeline but their excitement
didn't last long because well manal
didn't come back alone he's soon
revealed that he was actually married
which was super shocking his wife Erma
our Dean has been rubbing fans the wrong
way though so suspicions are at an
all-time high when it comes to Erma aka
Saturn girl a Reddit user was quick to
point out that the marriage was a sham
and caramel shippers are loving this
theory according to the reddit user Minh
L might the under Saturn girl spelled
making his marriage a total lie
in the comics Saturn girl is known for
having psychic and telepathic abilities
so Erma could easily be forcing Manila
to pretend that they're in a happy
relationship
actress amy jackson who plays Saturn
girl added fuel to the fire when she
stated that there is more to the story
than meets the eye what did the actress
mean by this could minal really be
brainwashed by his so-called white turn
already
fans seem to think so Superman Amun L go
way back playing with timelines can be a
tricky thing but sometimes our heroes
don't really have a choice
there's a popular theory floating around
that places Superman in the hot seat
redditor Megan Carter force
seems to think that man L and Superman
go way back but how is this possible
considering that they met for the first
time in season 2 well according to the
reddit user Superman was merely
pretending that he didn't know who man L
was Megan Carter 4 revealed that the
legion flight ring can be spotted in
season 1 in fact cars stumbled upon it
in the fortress of solitude but the
rings existence just doesn't make sense
when you think about it after all was it
man L the one who discovered the Legion
so
Superman already possessed the ring in
season one it means that he obtained it
by traveling to the future right so
here's where things get tricky since
Superman allegedly met Monell in the
future he'd still remember him after
travelling back to the present but man
now on the other hand would not because
well his present self wouldn't have any
recollection of the meeting after
meeting Cara's boyfriend for the first
time Superman tells her that he must be
a great guy well
Supergirl fans find this to be hilarious
considering that Superman knows exactly
what kind of guy he is the world killer
Theory DC you fans have been coming up
with wild theories ever since world
killers were introduced in the third
season of Supergirl in fact some are
even pointing accusatory fingers at some
of our favorite characters but we can't
deny that there's a method to their
madness world killers are terrifying to
say the least they were genetically
engineered by Kryptonians way before
Krypton was ever destroyed in fact many
of them were sent to earth before
Superman and Supergirl ever stepped foot
on it their anatomies were created using
dark magic which helped them to become
insanely resilient and powerful their
main mission in life is to purify sin by
cleansing the earth of its inhabitants
so you can see how this poses a problem
for our heroes well according to editors
Kara Danvers might be a world killer
herself although this is hard to believe
we have to face the facts some fans are
certain that Cara's father was a member
of the children of Giroux and that he
designed her to be a killing machine
fans also suspect that the Legion of
super-heroes knows that Kara is a world
killer however they're trying to stop
her from meeting her fate
Wonder Woman it can be hard to keep
track of all of DC's universes and with
so many timelines going on at the same
time it's easy for fans to hope for
crossovers that are likely never going
to happen but that hasn't stopped
Supergirl fans from coming up with a
very special theory fans took to Reddit
to theorize over a Wonder Woman
Supergirl crossover however some people
are certain that this crossover is
nothing but a rumor
after all actress gal gadot doesn't
usually
her Wonder Woman Sudan for a small cameo
especially not one that'll be featured
in a TV series the DCU and the DCE you
aren't known for crossing paths making
it very rare for an actor to retain his
role in both a DC film and TV series
with this in mind we're not so sure that
gal gadot will be making an appearance
on Supergirl
however that doesn't mean that a newly
cast Wonder Woman won't be showing up
anytime soon with this in mind fans were
shocked to see actress Melissa Benoist
appear in a short Wonder Woman movie
teaser and their suspicions skyrocketed
when Supergirl was seen wearing Wonder
Woman's classic boots nice boots
so does this mean that Wonder Woman will
be coming to the DCU they've got them
crossover aren't crossovers just
wonderful well fans seemed to think so
which is why they've come up with
another crossover theory however this
one is a bit more complicated than what
we're used to
Supergirl fans took to Reddit to explain
that Gotham might be linked to Supergirl
in more ways than one to be brief
they're convinced that Gotham actually
serves as a prequel to the Supergirl TV
series however people were quick to
point out that gotham airs on Fox
whereas Supergirl airs on the CW so by
default an actual crossover is very
unlikely
regardless fans couldn't help but notice
that Gotham and Supergirl use a lot of
the same characters however these
characters are never played by the same
actors with this in mind redditors
believe that both these shows exist in
different world
so while cara often references Batman at
Gotham City we're not so sure that the
city is sporting familiar faces fans
would love to see this crossover come to
life but it doesn't seem to be in the
works just yet a popular explanation for
this is that Gotham is happening decades
before Supergirl is so their timelines
simply don't match up
Alex will become Ruby's adoptive mother
Alex Danvers spent most of her life
keeping her secrets from anyone and
everyone despite having a supernatural
sister Alex built her career on tracking
aliens down and bringing them to justice
she's a talented fighter and brilliant
bio engineer so we weren't at all
surprised when she becomes the de
newest director Alex's life changed for
the better when she met detective Sawyer
Alex and Maggie worked side by side for
quite some time before the romantic
interests were made public
Alex soon realized that she was gay and
jumped into a relationship with Maggie
the pair seemed to be a match made in
heaven
until the subject of children came up
unfortunately their future goals didn't
line up because Alex wanted kids and
Maggie did not I'm always kind of so
their relationship came to an abrupt end
predator Shannon of the jungle is
convinced that a child is coming Alex's
way however not in the way you might
think she believes that Sam's alter ego
will be the death of her come season
four and that her daughter Ruby will be
adopted by Alex although we want Alex to
become a mom there has to be another way
does this theory seem to be possible to
you guys let us know in the comments
below
rain to the rescue Samantha arias is a
Kryptonian who is sent to the earth with
a very destructive mission implanted
into her brain she's a former world
killer who was adopted and raised by a
human although she might come off as a
normal human being
Sam's got a handful of Secrets up her
sleeve Sam
aka rain is super good friends with Alex
Cara and Lena
however the Legion has made it clear
that Sam is going to be disappearing
sometime soon which is pretty hard to
believe this is due to how close Sam and
her friends are we mean people don't
just disappear overnight without saying
goodbye besides what would this mean for
Ruby hopefully her mother will think to
bring her along for the ride predators
are desperately trying to make sense of
legions revelation and they've come up
with some theories that Sam will
temporarily disappear before coming back
as Supergirl zalae learning to control
your alter-ego isn't an easy thing to do
so we don't know how long Sam will be
gone for but we do suspect that Alex
will be asked to look after her daughter
do you guys think that Sam will join the
Hero Squad once she learns to control
her powers if she does dance Percy that
she'll come to supergirls rescue when
she needs it the most
Lena knows who's Supergirl is Lena
Luthor is a super genius who tends to
pick up on the smallest details so
why on earth can't she connect the dots
she and Cara have been friends for a
while now which is why we can't believe
that she hasn't cracked the code with
this in mind youtuber Christopher burger
II came up with the theory that she
actually knows who Supergirl is card
owners but she's pretending that she
doesn't for some strange reason fans
also predict that she will finally show
her true colors come the second half of
season 4 she's a Luthor after all right
well she was raised by them at least
fans pointed out that she has been in
close contact with both Supergirl and
Cara so by default she should have
noticed their uncanny resemblance since
she isn't a fool we're certain that
she's playing dumb however we have no
idea what she would gain by doing this
is she merely waiting for a friend to
confess her secret when she's good and
ready
or is she slowly building a case against
her she's surely noticed that car and
Supergirl shared the same height frame
features hairstyles and social settings
because well it is super obvious the
timeline was altered fans are dying to
know the real reason why Monell and Irma
have returned to National City although
many of us were hoping that mono was
returning to profess his love for Cara
this epic reunion hasn't happened just
yet fans took to the Internet during the
series hiatus to try and uncover the
truth what news could possibly be
holding on to and what does it have to
do with Supergirl according to fans
monel and Irma have returned to the 21st
century to help Supergirl fight the
world killers fans were quick to point
out that the Legion travelled back in
time from the 25th century to prevent a
game-changing event from occurring a
popular theory is that cara actually
died fighting the world killers however
the Legion went back in time to stop
this from going down so basically
they're there to help Cara beat the
world killers and stop the pass from
coming back to life Sam is destined to
become superwoman fans have been waiting
for superwoman to make her grand
appearance
well what if they've been staring at her
the entire time
according to redditors Sam is likely to
transform into superwoman at some point
or another it's easy to overlook this
possibility due to Sam being the seasons
big
bad there was no prison you can build
that can continue however once she rids
herself of her alter ego things might
start panning out if Sam didn't have a
daughter giving in to her dark side
would be a no-brainer
luckily Sam's daughter is her biggest
priority so she'll pretty much do
everything she can to see rain come to
an end
Lena recently announced that you once
stopped Sam get better and we suspect
that the genius is cooking up a master
plan it's possible that Sam turns into
superwoman after being subjected to a
strange LuthorCorp experiment after all
this wouldn't be the first time
something like this happens so there you
have it guys
ten of the best Supergirl fan theories
on the Internet
before you go make sure to let us know
which one was your favorite for feel
free to drop some theories of your own
in the comments section down below and
that's a wrap give this video a big
thumbs up if you love Supergirl and make
sure to subscribe to the things for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and see you next time
[Music]